this is episode 8 oh my god what an
ending
that was amazing you know if this
episode the fight thing is us watching
it and I think this is really good my
first thought was I'm not as that the
backstory for kingpin is good don't get
me wrong but it was kind of what I
thought it would be and the father kind
of seemed OneNote yeah the guy that
beats the wife and shit up be you doing
whatever it is she I know yeah you know
but they kind of made it interesting
that they made the wife kind of smart
but even then I'm kind of like but
what's she doing this guy and that like
I kind of want to know more about her in
a sense but especially what you just as
get the song I'm like what is this woman
get this off you know that she knew
obviously how to sort of get rid of the
body takes a bag a day down to the river
and stuff um so I'm not saying it's like
a bad character or anything I'm saying
that there's more information I think
needed
um but yeah everything else about him uh
god I just feel it's so bizarre I feel
the emotion for this guy even though
he's doing these awful things I mean for
me this is kind of he beats the living
shit out of his death boilers if you
feel every time you know that hammer yes
like the rage buried within that kid you
just it's like that scene in a Christmas
story on crack where he like beats the
crap out of the bully okay it's just
cool well and the beating of the being
of life was very intense but it was and
at first I was almost like it's just
getting a little exploitive but it was
it know when you see what's a building
out to do you have so yes that yeah it's
intense because of what it builds up to
it's all so intense and I think not
exploited because it's about the
reaction on the kid it's not hovering
over her or watching it just for a bunny
it's extreme just the sound and it's all
focused on Fisk
ya know every time she gets whacked like
he's just uh and you can see it building
within him so there wasn't like a
definite purpose to it yeah um and I
think the yeah I mean there's so much of
his focus on that nd but there is so
much good stuff and again we see more of
the silence when we see more than focus
on on Fisk and Wesley which I like and
how and and that is evanescent Saturday
yeah yeah I'll just try effect there now
of you got Wesley and Fisk with the
bromance and you've got Vanessa brought
into it which again the juxtaposition
because it's the trifecta
just like Murdock as he's Murdock has
foggy and yeah you're I am so it's three
and three now and this this whole thing
the whole show just does this and then
other there's like other little details
I notice like watching it a second time
the way Fisk's apartment is entirely
done in white steel it's it's high up
yeah I like why got some winter life I
think I made up for it yeah to get a
viewing the city versus Murdock's
apartment whether it's just his
apartment or the law office brick like
very like earthy kind of brick dark
yellows dingy so it's like the exact
opposite it's like Fisk is up kind of in
the heavens here in his ivory tower all
steel and everything and he's down in
sort of this British hell just details
like that like I love that and the suit
like when it comes out at the end he's
been wearing black for most of the show
yeah when he comes out there now we're a
gray suit well and what I love about
about that ending is that they're making
it look like well well they're gonna
take the chance they're gonna expose
this guy somehow it might cost them
their life but if they're gonna expose
it and then you see him there's this
talk about you gonna motional and you've
gotten weak and you get you know uh
what's-her-name it gal was everything
yeah I I mean she had a wonderful scene
with her I was waiting for her to kind
of like
because I said like you know she's gotta
speak English or what I mean beasts
talking seeds make no sense and why was
he even so what I like I like being I've
been revealed to things like not only
does she speak English and he speak
Chinese and the reverse but they both
speak Japanese well which they would
just all having so what she speaks like
all of them he we find out now at least
knows Japanese because he replies she
asks in Japanese because she used the
word nihongo like I started recognizing
some Japanese words and he said yeah it
was so yeah like they both speak
Japanese as well so they they're really
even smarter than we are me kind of
figured ya know a lot so uh but she had
this great big talk about like you know
you've got emotional and you've got
weekend of just restore balance to your
house to get in the most intimidating
way an old lady like that again smiling
just she's so sweet and demure but she
carries himself is only like an old
Chinese woman can with that sort of like
evil mother kind of like I whip you into
shape
goddamn she carries this very strong
confidence but also Authority yeah and
she's like an old Bo cheese she's like
those old ballet instructors I just
wanna see her with like a ruler or
something like yeah and I was kind of
waiting for her I was waiting for more
of her because I just saw her and she
always looked so confident like I want
to know more about her
so I'm glad she has the scene she found
out where he is and stuff like that um
and when she's leaving and he flips the
table I I could just feel his
frustration like big yeah like it's one
of those things man she was thinking
everything that intimidates him he's not
intimidated by no she donates me yeah
he's not intimidated by Nobu or Leland
or the Russians or you know even the man
in the mask still kind of feels like
nebulous and out there like when she
shows up like this the first time where
he's like okay he is really intimidated
by this short little Chinese well when
she talks to him like a parent and I am
obviously when it's at your house in
order
yeah but I mean she talked to like a
parent you know that is trying to be
helpful but you know Ken
yeah until the parent and really if it's
very wide to could just crush you
I mean no kid ever forget like version
person the punishment is not gonna be
good your room or you're grounded it's
gonna be I'm going to deal with other
people and you're probably gonna be out
of the picture yeah I think with most
parents I mean for every kid there's
this idea you know you love your parents
and everything but every kid is gonna
mess up in these be punished by a parent
and you never forget there's like
there's that authority there just even
with at best interference is always that
little bit of terror in the back of your
head like even if your parents are super
nice and hippy then there's always some
point where you feel like you could push
your parents too far and that's gonna be
bad well yeah and that's a part of the
the kid realizing it's like oh I can't
get away with everything you know every
kid unless maybe you're truly a troubled
psycho child and yeah I do what I want
but you know ya know you have to express
looking process yeah it's probably
process you find out about you know
everything is that you know there are
limits that anyone you know can be Boise
we know the scene afterwards with
because when Wesley comes in and that
rage when he shouts you know leave me
alone or whatever yeah I'm just like
fuck and again because of that great
scene with the Russian earlier we know
that he's capable of like it anybody
could snap on anybody like thankfully
he's friends with Wesley and so but you
saw that rage come out there for a
second like Mandan Leslie kept pushing
he may have been on the you know
receiving end of a good couple of blows
well and he's you know that scene you
feel so exposed watching it when she's
just in it's like cuz she painted this
house where does house that says you've
got emotional and weak which are two
things you know any aspect are true but
she's a waiting right but you don't
think are like that obvious to sort of
like he's trying to keep it hidden yeah
I mean it's not be so he's very much
everything controlling everything hidden
so just to become that exposed and in
your own house in your place where you
are safe you know is just I really felt
kind of the terror of that scene and
that insecurity and wait foots the table
I'm like guy if I was whatever
fuckin psychopath Rygel this is stuff
like YouTube the same thing I would just
feel so exposed and I thought that was
just so well handled but then to have
all of that come around to you know her
coming in it Vanessa coming in and you
don't notice like is this a good thing
or bad thing for him is she playing more
into the weakness or trying to play to a
strength than you think
while those wonderful words have being
written by that reporter and not just
about the guy but about you know
exposing the truth and everything about
this was about exposing it was just a
very exposed focused episode she's okay
with it yeah you're not a monster and
I'm like well herself yeah I mean I do
want control of him as well you know to
sort of figure this out it's like
there's something kind of almost
mothering about her like she's another
mother figure like almost taking care of
him but it's like a perverse mother
figure good I don't know I like when I
get more control over it I mean I'm sure
there is this level of life Carrie is
weird is she's clearly not all there oh
no no no no you you didn't let me finish
I I don't know if it's pure controlling
I think like when I say mother figure
that's what I'm saying it's like a
perverse mother figure though because
like a proper mother figure would like
take care of you me like it'll be okay
in this Annette but you need to do the
right thing whereas she's like I want to
take care of you I'm gonna help you
along you know do what you need to
overcome this but yeah I'm totally okay
with all these horrible things are doing
because she has to know - see I didn't
get as much I'm gonna take care of you
because I love you I with it the look on
her face every she still had a little
bit of a smirk it was more like you know
Oh goofy come on get yourself back
together we're gonna you know I know I'm
gonna get you out of that amigo we good
I don't know I don't know yet I think
the picking the suit and the and the way
they the way they show the backstory in
this one with the mother helping out
with disposing the body and the way she
probably has a dark side she's getting
rid of bodies and do
my and I don't know I seem like there's
a connection there like everything we
show but I'm not saying I don't think
it's just control like I'm in this just
for Fisk's money she seems to be living
a good life you know what she want more
money like I think she I think she
honestly cares for him but she's just
messed up you know what I see what I see
her with him I see her giving like a
little bit of a thrill being with them I
think there's a finite as well but I
don't think I don't think that's a
control thing like she's just doing it I
just want control no I mean like I guess
I don't see it as much as like a parent
thingy they're like sometimes she has to
be like the parent but it seems more
like I think it's like a twisted parent
I think there's something she's like
here's a here's like somebody who's
obviously broken and I can fix them like
but like not like you know what that
that is so much fun about I think about
her character it's like yeah we can't
call you Joe I can't say for sure we
don't know yet yeah I'm not saying I
know where that no it's clearly this
like I'm not entirely sure that part of
it yeah but Erica flashbacks and
everything that's kind of what I'm
reading into it um but who the hell
knows like you never know for sure well
and with that like I said with that
ending going on where she's picking the
suits and game the new cufflinks you
think like he's possibly becoming
quote-unquote weaker because he's liking
something come more vulnerable and stuff
you know to her and becoming emotional
and he's in love and stuff even though
gacho said this is not what you do and
then these words being written about to
expose this guy and then for him to come
out say expose himself I mean it just
who the hell will come out of you're
running these things and just to the
world expose who you are and this being
anti-drug thing just exposed like your
your cohorts and everything and just be
like you know I'm nervous about this but
I'm standing up and I'm gonna say this
and yeah just see oh my god this was all
part of just going the exact opposite
direction with this it ties into the
theme though because in the beginning
you know like I forget it was this
episode of the previous episode but you
know Karen
says straight up you know I need to do
this and yeah I'm scared I'm scared as
hell but I'm not gonna let these
bastards get away with it would ya
something that like is that the
characters who can beat upon who would
normally be your kind of useless
secondary characters who are just there
to get rescued by the superhero whatever
they keep taking a beating but they keep
coming back and they're just like no I'm
gonna do this and you wanna know why
because I am scared and I'm gonna face
that fear and Fisk perversely does the
same thing he doesn't want to be in
public he doesn't want his name out
there he's doing the same thing that
Karen and Murdock and foggy are doing
facing their fear now he's doing it and
it ends up screw the Murdock's play well
you know I'm glad you reminded me of
that scene because I really like when
she says you know it I I know I'm
terrified I'm so scared but I'm gonna
face I'm gonna stand up this is what to
do and I really knew Jay I knew one of
my favorite heroes that this is Brisby
from secret NIMH and some people could
be like well she does is hide and then
cover her head and is afraid to step by
that's exactly why cause she has a
fucking claw machine
she is afraid she is terrified of all
this stuff but she goes and does it
anyway and she is facing that fears and
it's I think when you could a dy the
heroes do yeah I mean and it's how
really well make the theater and how
much can you feel it and and the
environment you're going up against and
for me she's kind of like strangled
she's gonna be like she's she's taken
multiple beatings and she's still like
they're not gonna salesman a lot of
these characters yeah these are the
characters the good characters just take
multiple beatings and they still get up
but they're just like you know what is
it it'd take more than that to stop me
yeah and I think yeah there's something
you can see a hero you know this is why
something like I don't even know I
transform hers is an easy target you
know Optimus Prime going up against all
these robots oh no he's the make a big
hero he has a big sword on his way of
Lema he's not afraid of anything
and if there is no fear whatsoever you
know I'm not concerned by what he's
going up against cuz you haven't
established that there's anything to be
lost emotionally with the character
that's why they're doing this is crispy
in the characters and yet
you do get behind and you are inspired
by because everyone feels fear and they
have to confront it and they have to
figure out what to do with it and how to
come at it when to hide when don't know
former when to do all this stuff and
it's just a brainless maniac who goes in
killing people say yeah I mean it's like
unless you're doing a kind of comedy you
know there's nothing to the character
they're not interests and it all
connects together because that also is
the recurring theme with this with
Murdock's father is you keep take a beat
you keep taking a beating and you keep
getting up and the thing about Murdock's
father is that was the other Drex to
position I love when the show is seen
Fisk's dad liked it I'm like well it's
kind of what I expected this a man but
it works perfectly because you saw
Murdoch's dad these two are father
figures of a similar type they're their
brawny they're strong they don't seem
particularly bright you know they're
mostly physical types and one instills
important life lessons in his kid and
that's Murdock and the other does not
and that's Fisk yeah he has fear he
pounces in the two and both of them if
you think about it feel responsible well
in one case it literally is responsible
Murdock feels responsible for his
father's death because they asked him to
lose and the way in which both of them
die is the exact flip opposite Murdock
is used to taking a constant beating you
know and losing and the one time he
decides to fight to win to actually
stand up to win that's what gets him
killed Fisk on the other hand his you
know the old man fists basically is
constantly at least physically winning
he's beaten the crap out of the other
guys beaten the crap out of his wife
he's berating his kid you know and the
one one time you know basically luffa
stands up and just totally takes him out
so he goes down so one rose up you know
and goes down the other is always up hi
King the world he thinks are at least in
his own mind
he's brought down well now of course him
looking at the painting that he bought
and how looks exactly and the cowlings
and them yeah well no but the painting
especially how he would wake up and
that's the first thing he sees and even
the first time you see him in the show
you see him looking at that painting is
you know at first you just think he sees
something you know whatever you just
draw your own conclusion but then we see
how much the wall they looked at before
he fucking killed his father it's just
gonna be some artsy thing yeah and he
just looks at my painting because it
represents something and we're never
gonna explain it and they actually do in
a way that it wasn't fine went on it's a
little bit funny but this way actually
did it than it honestly didn't feel like
a compa no I'm like okay this all
connected together really nicely look
yeah you write a good story I think the
only other little thing I noticed was uh
I like I like the way just going back to
the two different fathers and how they
react to things if you remember and this
is because I've seen it twice now but
Murdoch's dad gives him you know some
Scotch to steady his hands and he uh
burns and the dad just kind of slopes it
off and laughs a little and it was like
whatever like stay in school kids isn't
like demands a visit quick drink it and
when he doesn't spits it out he just
breaks a bar yeah it's hilarious you
know my kids are freaking idiot like and
again just to similar scenes and a boy's
first drink you know offered from his
dad like and one just just perfectly
comes off as like natural and yeah
that's okay and the other just is such a
douche yeah moment so again the
juxtaposition it's like you now see
these two characters and how they're
both exactly the same and polar
opposites you and I are very similar yes
I hate that my cuz it doesn't need to be
said but no it doesn't many said because
the show writes it well enough about a
BSF but it's a common comic book trope
and the common trope and a ton of things
but this is one of the best executions
of it I haven't never see it really is
um because it takes its time to show it
as well and again that is the
having it as a it's almost biblical if
you know it's like this satanic kind of
argument do this do well like it's
really what it should be when comics are
at their best yeah um the last thing
I'll say I'll make a little bit of a
comparison here a lot of people like ask
what I think of Breaking Bad and I know
it's like a different show and my big
arguments for the first two seasons I
don't it's well it's a good show
I don't like any of the characters I
just find them so unlikable and that's
kind of a point uh but I will say with
uh with Walter White
I think the kingpin here is kind of what
I wanted to see with Walter White where
he is despicable and he's doing these
awful things but at the same time there
is just this real emotion this real
understanding of his mental state and
I'm not saying that Breaking Bad didn't
do that it did show what he was going
through but I did not feel as much for
him the the way he sir came to these
conclusions makes more sense with the
kingpin than it does with Walter White
and as part of the Walter White
character he's just supposed to kind of
be nuts but I understand this insanity
much more than Walter White's insanity
and it's still good so he hasn't seen it
so III I've only seen season one and I
liked a lot
I just what his days I'm gonna binge
watch all of them I haven't yes you see
you know tie in that again we like this
kind of the idea that they think he is
nuts and he will almost have the split
personality but I know the argument
you're making I would be unfair me to
just say I blank and we agree with that
but as you know with if I haven't seen
it so I'm not going to do it but I know
what you're saying cuz in other shows
I've seen some way things there is a
humanity to Fisk and that's always the
thing I find villains who are human more
scary than just I'm just a monster and
visit that like it not scary to me it's
the ones that are human because you
always want to try to rationalize with
the human side and at any second that
can snap yeah it's just really yeah and
and you're just on the other side of a
gun now going I can't believe like
that's what most murders are committed
by people you know yeah oh I never knew
is that yeah 60 63 percent chance or
something crazy that if you were to get
murdered it would be somebody you know
and there's a great line I think it was
eight millimeter we're talking about the
thing that gets me most is it's the
surprise and like that's when you have a
human character kill something there's
more of a surprise we need to say oh
they're a monster this and that there's
no surprise to them but when a human
does it it's truly scary yeah because
you always think I can rationalize my
way out or maybe I can do this it's like
but if you just lose that human side
then those brief instances like with
Fisk it's like oh oh Mike tried to cozy
up to him trying to be his friend still
get your head take it off like yeah I
just wanna be iterative a little fast to
it said I I like Breaking Bad and Walter
White is a great examination of a carrot
I'm not saying it's bad by any means I
just could not relate with him like I
relate with a character like the kingpin
so no comment
but yeah so I again it's just
complimenting just what a what a great
character it is and just when you think
it's going one direction
man are they good at throwing a nice
little spin on it I know I guess I
thought at the end of this I had it
figured out I'm like oh I'm like okay
now it's gonna be kingpins revenge
because he's been out in now visit and
I'm like oh where are we going I was
like did not see that one and they
should appreciate that now that the
storytelling but the characters that
they thought of this and that they it's
like you thought you knew this guy you
thought you knew more about this guy but
they keep throwing these surprises at
you and they they're understandable
they're the most part they're all smart
they're not bleeding idiots honestly I
think that the to the Russians seemed
kind of dumb and then the priming the
two biggest idiots just for lack of just
actual smarts is probably just the two
dads so far like most everybody is
pretty scheming pretty conniving even
Karen and foggy like they're using their
brain most others hatch Adams guy he's
getting a little dumb but he's still
staying in the game okay Oh Leland yeah
I don't think he's dumb like you know
it's just emotional life I think he's
playing all sides honestly he's just a
complainer at jesse complainers but yeah
these these
workers are dumb and it makes them more
interesting to watch but they still have
false they're still interesting they're
still yeah but and relatable so yeah
love them it can't wait to see what we
got like five left something like that
yeah I cook so I'm excited I'm like
really excited to see where it's going
and we'll see what the next one later